359 paire de bottes 359 coquelicot pour
autant de soldats canadiens tombés sur
les plages de dieu nos beach le jour j
en tout la bataille de normandie a coûté
la vie à plus de 5000 jeunes canadiens
beaucoup n'avaient même pas 20 ans tous
étaient volontaires et ils ont tout
risqué pour la liberté de pays lointains
la france aujourd'hui leur doit beaucoup
le premier ministre edouard philippe a
tenu à le rappeler pour ceux qui
viennent après il est difficile de dire
autre chose que mercy mais ce mercier
est immense
[Musique]
75 ans se sont écoulés depuis ce matin
de juin 1944 qui a changé le cours de la
deuxième guerre mondiale qui a changé le
cours de l'histoire
jean 30 venez juste tout juste d'avoir
19 ans lors du débarquement de normandie
et pourtant une poignée d'anciens
combattants de l'époque sont encore
vivants en leur rendant hommage
le premier ministre justin trudeau peine
à retenir ses émotions
il se souviendra toute sa vie du carnage
dont il a été témoin ce jour là si les
anciens combattants était très émue par
la cérémonie
la plupart ont surtout apprécié la fin
le moment pour eux d'aller déposer une
gerbe de fleurs sur la plage en plage
que certains n'avaient pas revus depuis
75 ans c'est le cas de l'acadien
alphonse vautours bientôt 100 ans qui ne
peut cependant s'empêcher de penser à
ses frères d'armes disparu beaucoup de
souvenirs
je suis honoré de pouvoir participer à
la célébration
j'en tremble pour sa part n'a pas pu
résister pour que l'expérience soit
complète il devait absolument y mettre
aussi les pieds
j'ai été me mouiller les pieds dans
l'eau fallait que j'aille tout tu as
touché aliot
[Applaudissements]
je suis un geste simple pour aider à
chasser de vieux démons et se donner un
autre souvenir de la normandie ici jean
françois bélanger radio-canada à
courseulles sur mer